so you may have read in the news that
Joe Biden just made America a little
better by sending the Speak Out act into
law it's supposed to combat sexual
harassment which you probably didn't
read is that Joe Biden himself has been
credibly accused of sexual misconduct
and not just by his own daughter whom he
showered with
in the presidential election in 2020
Tara read a woman called Tara Reid
emerged to say that while working for
Joe Biden in the U.S Senate he sexually
assaulted her in a violent way most the
media buried the story and we'll be
honest and admit that we didn't know
what to think of it but we finally sat
down and talked at Great length with
Tara Reid to hear what happened and we
were completely convinced that this is
real and that she was able to prove it
the whole story is part of a brand new
episode of Tucker Carlson today but
here's part of it
[Music]
when Biden started acting weird towards
me he would like put his hands on my
shoulder and put his fingers underneath
my hair and do weird things like that
and then there was a scene where did you
think of that I mean did you well you
know bear in mind and you were around in
a professional in the 90s it was a
different I don't know if you were in DC
but it was a difference okay that was a
different vibe but it still was weird I
never had an employer do that and
Panetta certainly didn't act like that
no he's done no not at all and um he's
just all business and
um you know Joe Biden was always he
didn't seem like an intellectual giant
let's put it that way right no he was
famously not yeah charismatic and warm
guy
you know and that's the thing behind
closed doors he was very
um he's very temperamental and he would
do this thing where he smiles when he's
angry it's very disconcerting very
disconcerting that big smile and he's
ain't you know but he'd be angry and he
was he was very temperamental he had me
up against a wall and he penetrated me
with his fingers against my will and I
um you know it was it wasn't just the
assault though
um it was it was everything to do with
here I am this young staffer and he did
this and then I made him angry and
that's like someone you don't want to
make angry because I said no I just
think it's I got to be honest one of the
reasons I didn't know what to make of
your story was it's so I've been a man
for you know 53 years yeah I've never
heard of anything like that that's you
know men do men men are kind of piggish
as we know and they do pigish things but
that's like
that's like kind of like rape I mean
that's like so out of
he bounds that it's weird to think
someone would do something like that
it was just it happened all at once it
happened really quickly there was no
like flirtation with him or anything
like that it was very you know um
he's you he was usually with people and
he wasn't I was like at the wrong place
the wrong time so to speak and when it
happened
um
he at first was like come on man I heard
you liked me
and I you know I froze and then he said
he got angry and that's when he smiled
you know that smile and that's what was
really jarring and then he said he
pointed his finger in my face and he
said you're nothing
you're nothing to me
and then I I must have had a certain
look on my face and he just took my
shoulders and shook him he said you're
fine you're fine you're fine and then he
turned around he walked away
and I remember it was just such a
jarring shocking incident probably was
all of less than five minutes right
but my vivid memory is sitting on these
marble stairs and my legs were shaking
so badly
because it wasn't just what he did it's
that I knew
my career was over
that was it
like I had said no it was an awful thing
and this was the end he used his power
and resources to silence me
and I'm going to share something with
your audience
they took a cannonball to my life
they went after my family
so when that day when he did that
assault he took my future
I didn't want to sleep with some Senator
I wanted to be one
and that day
it ended
the cruelty she describes not just an
unwanted Advance not just the sexual
violence but the meanness to her
from Joe Biden and from his staff and
from people throughout the Democratic
party will just absolutely blow your
mind is really offensive to anybody not
on partisan grounds but just as a human
being you can't believe people would act
that way but they did so we called the
White House and we asked them for
comment on what Tara Reid told us of
course they didn't respond you can watch
the whole interview tomorrow morning on
Fox
on Fox Nation subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight